reaching chernahiv meant risking your
life under russian fire until a couple
of days ago
that's when russian troops pulled back
lifting a siege around this city letting
in life
and revealing huge trauma
antonina had been a street cleaner
before russian shelling on her home
shattered her body
she lost a leg some fingers an eye but
not her spirit
this awful trauma has happened to you
and yet you're still smiling
how are you doing that
monica
yes
doctors have been living and working in
their hospital since the war started
dealing with hundreds of victims
this place was shelled too
forcing them to operate in the basement
[Music]
evidence of russia's war isn't hard to
find
the ukraine hotel took a direct hit from
an airstrike
close to the borders with russia and
belarus chernohev was targeted from the
first days of the invasion
ukrainian forces fought back hard but
this official says at least 300 people
across the region died in the
bombardments and he accused russian
soldiers of war crimes
um
the city is starting to open up again
yet reminders of the past week's loom
large
the attack here happened at four in the
morning on the 15th of march fortunately
many of the residents had already been
evacuated so they weren't killed but
this is clearly a residential building
we've also heard about hospitals and
schools being hit but the devastation
would have been even worse had russian
forces not been pushed back
nadia lives in the block and showed us
some of the damage
worrying times
water in short supply too
the fighting may have moved away here
for now
but not the weight of war
debra haynes sky news chernhiv